hello everyone and welcome to day two of
the Grantchester is your next move
boo it's tournament in Leuven after nine
rounds of blitz on day one it was Wesley
so in the lead and today we're gonna see
can he keep that lead here we go here we
have a game from round 13 at 11:00
Arnhem versus Hikaru Nakamura in the
previous game Hikaru Nakamura completely
obliterated giri in a very nice game
with the white pieces but that it's big
it's too short of a game to show so I
will just put a link to that game in the
description below so you can check it
out it's quite a nice tactical
achievement so before we check out the
game we do have a nice photo challenge
so it's a pretty famous poor photo I'm
pretty sure most of you will know who
this person is
let's just check it out so best of luck
to everyone who is the person on the
left now it's it's pretty famous photo
was taken in 1972 but for those of you
who are interested in some extra points
you can also try and figure out who the
person on the right is so best of luck
to everyone now let's check out this
game alright that has the white pieces
and he opens with E 4 we have C 5 the
Sicilian nice the C 3 now they are going
for the closed Sicilian d6 Knight g29 of
6 and now G 3 and G 6 so both players
prepare to fianchetto their bishops
brush of G 2 bush of g 6 g 7 we have
castles castles d3 and knights the c6
Bishop to g5 we have rook to b8 Knight
to d5 and the 98 and it was somewhere
around here that Aragon really started
losing a lot of time on the clock and
you know especially in this game
everyone was really praising Nakamura
how he he's a monster when it comes to
time management
we have c3h6 pushing the Vishram back
Bishop to d2 and now b5 and we have F 4
e 6 forcing Knight back to e 3 9 3 7 G
for now and d5 we have E 5 and now a 5
here in a Kimura really creates a nice
expansion and on the Queen side
d4c capture some d4 CCAP for some d4 and
now
before and here if it was a classical
game or some or perhaps even a rapid
game surely a move like rook to c1 will
be played but this is blitz and here are
and immediately goes for it he pushes f5
now you don't wanna you don't want to
capture here if you play something like
captures captures captures captures
captures then White's just gonna
sacrifice the exchange and after G
captures an i-5 plane 93 the queen is
gonna come to h5 there's gonna be a very
nice attack going on against the black
king king h1 is coming the other rope is
coming to g1 so what would have more
than enough compensation for the 40
exchange sacrificed so after a5 Nakamura
plays the strongest move f6 and he plays
it instantly so he is not you know
attacks like these are no no strangers
to him we have F captures on e6 Bishop
captures on e6
nice to f4 Queen to b6 defending the
bishop and Queen to b3 of course the d4
pawn is I like is unable to capture on
d4 as the bishop on e6 is hanging rook
to d8 we have Knight captures Queen
captures and it captures on f6 Knight
captures on f6 and here rook 81 is
played and in this position it's
interesting Arnon had 18 seconds on the
clock when he played rook e1 and he
pressed the clock and nakamora had 3
minutes and 30 seconds so it's a pretty
equal position but 18 seconds against 3
minutes and 30 seconds very hard to play
Knight captures on g4 so because Irina
was in such a time trouble nakamura
decides to sacrifice a piece we have
Makarov characters on f8 rook captures
and I fade and now Knight captures on g4
Queen captures on g4 rook captures on e7
and now Queen captures on d4 with Czech
Bishop captures on d4 was also possible
the this was possible with a nice trick
King H 1 and now roof to F 1 Bishop
captures Queen you want checkmate about
that from Bishop captures and before
Bishop to e3 comes and you don't really
have a good way of continuing this so
Nakamura try the Queen captures on d4
with check we have Bishop to e3 blocking
and Queen back to a
or attacking the rook on e7 Queen
captures on d5
this comes with check came to h8 and now
again very very low on time a couple of
seconds on the clock
origins rook on e7 is under attacked
under attack and here with Bishop to c5
he protects the rook
he keeps the extra piece black has
nothing he would easily win this game if
he had time on the clock of course but
here after King to a trade we have rook
to f7 and now okay your rook is no
longer under attack but what about Queen
e1 check picking up the bishop so that's
what happens I won at 2800 player has a
couple of seconds on the clock
he will blunder so rook to f7 was played
and now you can either first capture and
then play Queen e1 check and a camera
immediately played Queen to e1 check we
have rogue back to everyone and now
Queen captures on e3 winning back the
piece King h1 and now rook captures an
f1 Bishop captures and queen to c1 so
they are bishops of opposite color and
you know usually you can maybe force
this into a draw but the bishop is under
attack
also the b2 phone is under attack and
the nakamura will be up two points we
have Queen to see for guarding the
bishop and not win capture some b2 now
Nakamura is up two points and now this
is a winning position of course it's a
blitz game you know you can you never
know Bishop to d3 trying to create some
sort of an attack against the g6 pawn
Queen to f6 blocking Queenie for
attacking King to h7 now the point is
defended h4 h5 nakamora of course
doesn't allow Aragon to push h5 we have
King to g2 Queen d6 and now rush up the
c2
bunch of 3/5 Queen to d3 offering a
trade of Queens and although this isn't
good for white the position is winning
for black there is no good move for
white here but onion things that would a
couple of seconds on the clock and with
his king being so open it will be easier
to play with only bishops on the board
so nakamora declines it we have Queen to
c6
Queenie for offering a trade Queen back
to f6 Queen to f3 again offering a trade
and here we have Queen to e6 it's hard
to say did Nakamura now blunder Queen
captures on h5
or did he calculate that this was
winning for black it's hard to say but
okay Queen captures on h5 would check
Nakamura simply moves the king and here
with Queen to e2 the game continues now
Nakamura is only up one point and you
know it's not so simple with opposite
colored bishops if the Queen's get off
the board it will be very difficult but
after King to g7 Queen to g5 was played
by iron and now it simply does not work
anymore
Queen to c6 was played this comes with
check King to f1 and now you cannot
capture the bishop immediately as Queen
captures Bishop here but now you
simplify either Queen to a3 check or
what Nakamura played in the game Queen
to c4 check now King has to move and now
what once the King is on a dark square
this Bishop death was under attack can
move this comes with check and now Queen
captures on c2 and 11 wasn't really
bothered by this because he thought he
still thought that sorry about this
Queen e7 followed by Queen g5 would lead
to a perpetual check and in the draw by
repetition but the problem is after this
end and when Nakamura played King to h6
are immediately resigned because he saw
all wait it's not it's not a perpetual
because if the Queen checks back then
the King can go to h7 and once the King
Queen checks back the bishop blocks and
now it's simply up a piece and up upon 4
Nakamura completely winning position so
yeah after King to h6 our onion
unfortunately was this game even though
he played an excellent game and Nakamura
blunders the game in a position where he
has so I mean three minutes on the clock
in our onion only has a couple of
seconds i but with those couple of
seconds nakamura played whatever and it
was enough to beat eleven aria so a very
nice game and the very complicated game
really shows you that you know it's
sometimes it's better it's better to
play a lesser move but to preserve time
then you know to waste all this time to
find the best move and then you don't
really have enough time to avoid
blunders you know quite quite the
educational game so once again I do hope
you enjoyed it the best of luck to
everyone
photochallenge I would like to thank
Matthew saw it den o'hanlan Konstantinos
ma Primanti's and Leon fudou lien for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and thank you
all for your best wishes for my birthday
you know on all of my social media are
really really happy to see that and yeah
we're gonna check out one more game at
least one more game from day two of the
blitz tournament and we're gonna check
out the standings of course after the
final round and see can obviously so
keep it or will Carrick in who is in
amazing form in this blitz section
overtake Wesley so so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it once again as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon with another nice game
from Ruben thank you